Kobe smallville smolders to be kidnapped
I'm like I'm sure that it's like I mean
I didn't really cheat i kidnapped Jack
Reacher was like what the [ __ ] the
second he was like I gotta take on the
government yeah it seems like there was
a point in the trailer where it kind of
started to lose me where I got a little
too big I don't know I feel like that
can either be really cool and it'll just
like somehow become this kind of looks a
lot more straightforward or if it'll tip
over and just kind of give in to
indulgence and not work afterlife
because there is a mystery and reveal
vibe with the first one this feels like
it doesn't contain any of that well on
the first one I like a Grimm all I want
to know is yeah the first one had like
it was like a slow burn kind of thriller
in a lot of ways do the action sequences
look cool yeah they do but there's also
an edginess that I feel is missing see
Miss from the trailer for the first one
I remember thinking like this look that
looks violent like the funny is like
[ __ ] up those guys at the bar well
this like this this looks like they were
taking action my scenes yeah well some
of it looks like action season some of
it looks like they were trying to take
notes off of taken I feel like this
movie could just end up being just like
this trailer but a little bit long the
mystery i'm left with isn't enough to
make me like yeah i gotta see this no it
just looks like an action movie with a
straight for reply
hello rejects it's greg here hello
rejects its John here a few days ago I
posted a quick movie review of jack
reacher never go back first I claimed it
was the worst movie I've seen all year I
know there's films are probably worse
that out of the film's I have seen in
the theaters this is the worst one I've
seen now I've thought about it since
then and now I would say that that is
still true yeah it is the worst movie
I've seen passion about that I do not
like this movie at all i think it's a
terrible terrible movie haven't asked
john what he thought yeah John now that
we're on camera what did you think buddy
I mean I don't disagree with anything
that you said I think because I was
prepared for something really bad it
didn't really strike me like I don't
feel strongly about it I'm not like oh
it's terrible but there's not really
much this isn't it is right or like with
any distinct Flair the best thing about
this is tom cruise at the same time Tom
Cruise is still kind of phoning it in
actually I think I think he totally is
phoning in and I don't think he really
had much depth or intensity in this role
he didn't really seem to let things
really affect him there were these
moments in the film that were trying so
like not even that hard it was like
inserts of you could just feel
screenwriters going hmm here's that we
can make this feel more personal cuz the
first one he was so mysterious let's
make this one feel more personal I feel
like it's the movies fault more than I
would put that blame on Tom Cruise
himself cuz least when I was watching it
he didn't look disengaged to me like I
don't think they really wrote Jack
Reacher to be much of a character and
like he's Superman like to me he's to me
he's like my I saw with andrew from
movie source channel yeah and he put it
best he's kind of like the Terminator in
the film where the Terminator is kind of
on a road trip with sarah connor and
connor yeah and that's his role but see
terminator works cuz sarah connor john
connor have a whole history there's this
whole feeling towards the terminators
here you got these three strangers going
on like some weird road trip in the
beginning of the move
and it doesn't make sense the what
they're going for is not felt I didn't
really care for any of the personal
stuff they tried including it felt like
forced dialogue it felt like inserts and
this movie felt like a large outline to
me where the large quantity of scenes
with horrible transitions between scenes
a scene end next thing next scene they
cut to you they're like sprinting to
somewhere I'm like wait a minute the
[ __ ] the guy I've never haven't even
explained where they're going there's
one moment where Cobie Smulders like
this prostitute like puts a phone in a
guy's pocket the chief she comes up to
Cobie Smulders I did what you told me to
do or some [ __ ] next scene Cobie
Smulders I did it like yeah there's no
the time lapse is here it is so poorly
edited and so poorly done terrible
transitions I feel like we transition
every every few see like everybody gets
a running montage in this movie there
seems more like everyone's running
together and that's how we get from
chapter chapter is like the next time
they're running you know the plots about
to move yeah this movie feels like an
airport novel through the imagination of
someone who's just not thinking very
hard about it you pointed this out to
man I think this is the biggest flaw
this movie has is like this movie wants
you to believe that Jack Reacher is this
like incredibly skilled incredibly
focused you know intense ex-military guy
with a past and all that so catches
everyone in the world is kind of dumb
yeah everyone's dumber every week Jack
Reacher looks smarter that whole prison
breakout is robbed of any goodness when
you're like this does this is impossible
like no one gives his [ __ ] people were
opening it like if he goes to the door
and says we're done here I don't think
they're just gonna open the door cuz he
saids yeah like there's any dough sent
the lawyer that guards somebody like no
one in this movie has a protocol and
like yeah that whole prison breakout is
so unbelievable that it loses any and
all flavor and it's I felt like there
were moments for Cobie Smulders and Tom
Cruise had chemistry yeah but the
writing of Cobie Smulders and just their
dialogue back and forth when it gave to
that scene when they're in the hotel and
she's like it's because I'm a woman and
I'm like could you not go for the most
the thing about the personal stuff they
go for here to make it more character
it's the most cliche care
stuff you could have gone for there's no
real depth it's more it's more of the
most surface level cliche [ __ ] you could
have possibly con conjured up well the
problem is I think that's a cool seem to
want to have like I think that's a cool
argument for them to get into because
it's relevant now like it's a thing that
we have to deal with you know like oh
what's a woman's experience as a high
ranking military officer shamanism
they're all that moment it is though
like the movie doesn't handle it very
well and it doesn't get deep into it so
I'm like um snaps for trying but I wish
you tried harder killing or had a better
character with which to kind of explore
this with cuz i think cobie smulders is
good in this I wasn't thinking about
Robin Scherbatsky the whole time so like
that's a good thing the writing is real
thin I felt like Cobie Smulders was
trying a lot harder than Tom Cruise was
yeah you're like she's got some to prove
I feel like Tom Cruise is such a
naturally great actor that even when he
phones it in he's going to do a good
enough job but it's it's just a passable
job in this film for me he phones in the
same way like Johnny Depp phones in
something Tom Cruise's Jack Sparrow to
me is what Jack Reacher has become as
like oh yeah the guy who's kind of like
assure that all of his skills are gonna
get through yeah I always one step ahead
and like he's badass that's his kind of
fall back character to me and you know
he's fine I don't know like there are
times i liked the three of them together
but even that story what they choose
Auto you weird that little girl was so
annoying I'm 50 what I hate it there
were times at the beginning like early
on Roz like yeah i get i get what your
life is so I get why you're so
frustrated and so mad but there were
times later where they they would like
flip flopper character between like
being cool and having fun and being
angry and broody and I was like I don't
know I wish I just fleshed out any of
your characters like they're supposed to
be like 15 or 16 years old man watching
some of the choices she made I'm like I
get she's a kid but she cannot be that
dumb she just can't she can't be that
dumb while also the movies trying to
tell you that she's you know a lot like
Jack Reese yeah like there's this one
mode x that was the worst part to me
like what the most cliche lines at one
point she's on the
and Jack & Co beats was like where'd she
go and Jack Reacher's like cuz cuz they
don't know if this is Jack Reacher's
daughter or not that's the big question
of the film Lori is this Jack Reacher's
daughter and then when Jack Reacher's
trying to figure out where she went he's
like she did this and with no real
explanation as to why Jack Reacher knows
that he just goes because that's what I
would ya what I raveena there going oh
my god can't believe he said that yeah
and like they just doesn't earn that
really oh well doesn't it doesn't so to
say that she does a bunch of others
because wood will lead to her but letter
having to run was a stupid move of her
using a credit card and at this point in
the movie it's like wait a minute you've
been on this adventure with him for
quite some time now you should know
better than to use a credit card when
she decided to use this credit card the
scene I heard murmurs in the whole
audience like what a [ __ ] idiot who
would do that at this point after
everything you've been through one like
if you know who Jack reaches like
there's an especially after the there's
an incident with the cell phone and
stuff like you know that they would have
explained that now to her this movie is
full of befuddling characters and it's
like it I feel like this movie wants to
be a Bourne movie but just like that
doesn't have a writing team yeah there
was this funny actor Patrick Hugh singer
he is the bourne assassin the assassin
knew how every board movie has that one
assassin is going after born he is that
guy in this film see the thing is I like
that guy's performance in a way as the
big baddie like a personal vendetta guy
like I like that actor but own man he's
like it's weird self-assured character
who's not good at his job at all yeah
like I'm like you're terrible at this
but you have the same attitude people
really good at this house is a very
confusing performance to watch as he's
always one step behind and it always
looks like he's [ __ ] up like every
single time Jack Reacher speaks to his
characters like he [ __ ] up now see I
have been taking any time to really
compare this to the first one now I
wasn't the biggest fan of the first one
but here's what i will say about the
first one is that there is such a
definitive style to it there's a grit to
it there's a substance to it it's a kind
of it's like a slow burn kind of miss
to rebuilding thriller everything that
you loved about or really enjoyed
especially yeah I hated the action
scenes in this movie and never go back I
thought the action scenes were so poorly
cut together he is so poorly edited some
of the action scenes just seem like what
was the point of this whole fight
exactly this did not need to happen yeah
it's like they just felt like we do you
have an action scene here this one I
could really feel edward zwick stepping
in and giving his melodramatic input in
this movie and that's what the prom was
with the drama it was so melodramatic so
forced kind of cheesy it didn't fit in
it tonally with the rest of this movie
they're trying to blend in a new thing
which I which is cool like I again like
this movie has ideas i like but going
back to the action it's like the movie
doesn't give the action a chance to work
cuz you're already distracted by the
fact that the logic doesn't check out
and these people aren't very good at
their fights and then yeah the fights
are kind of assembled in a not
particularly dazzling way like I didn't
have many problems of the way the film
was like shot like the way they framed
things the best fight in this movie is
you know kind of cool at best I feel
like there's no real specific type of
style or tone to this film it does feel
like Airport novel to your right it just
feels like a like a bad born novel like
it wants to have that like Oh intrigue
and military stuff and and you know but
it's not intriguing yeah it's not a
mystery is not that exciting and I felt
smarter than a lottery and everyone in
this movie and then and like the
henchman like they're this movie is
filled with henchmen who are just
terrible fishman and there's there's
like that general villain there's a
who's like wait a minute I I don't you
haven't even really set up who this guy
is you're trying to make this like pay
off towards the end a big deal yeah man
oh that yeah the the guy from prison
break the like a private military yeah
tractor thanks for giving us credit to
be able to figure that out but we should
have had an intro to this guy or
something and I hated that scene okay
they're minor spoiler alert there's this
one scene where Cobie Smulders and Tom
Cruise bring gang with them they're like
about to crack down on ya
like looking for MP force blow the thing
wide oh and then they open they open
these cases as rocket launchers in there
well then they're basically looking for
empty cases but all the cases have what
they're supposed to have inside of them
when they were just about to give up I I
look to Andrew and I was like why are
they just like look under the case or
take the thing out of the case and look
at it in for a second instead of just go
ahead what looking in for face value
yeah and then sure enough Tom Cruise
like a couple minutes centres like
something's not right yeah let me look
at this is like a second later he
figures out like I do that too and well
horrible foreshadowing in the film too
with the little girl learning how to
randomly you know get out of a situation
where a guns don't let her the very
split second it came up on screen and
you look to me he's like oh well they're
showing us this cuz she's gonna use it
later on something important down bro
they tried doing it like in a clever way
where oh this is just some fun bonding
moment but it was so obviously setting
my dismisses yeah exactly and it's so
obviously set up for something big I
just felt that especially with the
action sequences after watching Jack
reach like I feel like even if you're
not a big fan of the first Jack Reacher
one of the great things it has is its
action sequences where the camera steady
yeah and a lot of it's like in wide
frames you can see the action very clear
what's going on it feels rather real and
they do that with the fistfights and the
car chase sequence here it's like all
choppy it's a little not like crazy born
status handheld but it's still like not
entirely clear what you're seeing it so
it's hard to grasp is really the
choreography of what's going on to let
the impact relief to let it feel I
remember watching the first Jack return
going like oh like that looks painful
this one it just looks like a pg-13
action movie yeah there were there were
only a handful of moments during fights
and not even full fights there only a
couple of like specific shots or
specific kills or whatever that were
kind of cool to me but this movie
doesn't have a distinct flare on almost
any level and there are times when it
gets near it there are times where
you're like almost oh maybe it's picking
up now cuz this movie it has that thing
where it feels like it's dragging but
it's also going so many places at once
gets it keeps moving from location to
location I'm they were on the run and
things are happening and we're cutting
back and forth between different stories
but it drags I knew it was not going to
be a good film from the second the
opening montage happened between him and
Cobie Smulders the first scene they have
is that one cool scene in the trailer
where he's like the sheriff's are about
to arrest him then he says some badass
[ __ ] yeah rings and that was a cool
scenes like alright Jack Reacher's back
then it immediately hops into this
montage of Cobie Smulders and Tom Cruise
talking over the phone as he travels
doing his Mad Max thing and just keep
talking with her and bonding with her I
felt like why not just give us like one
really good scene of them talking with
each other the last time before he
decides to go visit her that establishes
history and you could feel it he could
feel the scene I felt like what this
movie did a lot of was it gave us such a
large quantity of scenes but no real
quality in any of the scenes and that's
what I really appreciate about the first
Jack Reacher was it's not filled with a
[ __ ] ton of scenes when there is a scene
there's a lot of quality in the scene
that allows it to be an effective film
here it's just like just scene after
scene if it's like I'm like I don't know
how many [ __ ] scenes this movie has
there's just so much at many where it's
like dude you gotta slow to him a little
bit and just let one Scene do its work
instead of just keep hopping the [ __ ]
around yeah actually write a few of
these scenes you know out like that
whole thing with Jack Reacher like there
are no consistent rules on them yeah cuz
like he's supposed to be this eglin I
couldn't help but think about Halloween
when he's first following the girl who
could be his daughter around like poking
out from behind a bush and stuff like
that and then she's immediately able to
detect that he's been following her yeah
how good is he yeah exactly yeah that
you got caught by a fifteen-year-old
girl yeah like either she is the most
advanced fifteen-year-old girl ever or
you're not very good at this and the
movies conclusion just kind of both I
was all right with this for the first 25
minutes or so I was like yeah you know
this could be alright but yeah what's it
really kicked in what really makes yeah
what's the plot kicks it just gets in
such as ridiculous territory and I found
myself so just waiting for this movie to
end yeah like when it got to the whole
cliche thing towards the finale were
heroes you know like possible daughter
might get kidnapped her kidnet like
sorry minor spoiler there but it happens
in almost every [ __ ] generic action
film were the heroes daughters getting
kidnapped I just couldn't believe they
regard with that cuz i like this movie
she's never gonna [ __ ] it and is it well
this is this movie doesn't really
convince you of anything and that was a
drawback to me as like I never had any I
wish there would be a little intrigue or
a little doubt as to who we can trust
and stuff like that and you pretty much
know who's evil the whole time and I
think I just think they look the
daughter danica arusha Irish something
like that I think the writing of her was
terrible and I think her performances is
not that good I'm not gonna say she's a
bad actress but I will say this
performance specifically wasn't a good
performance there were times were there
were times when I was alright with her
there were times when I wasn't and I
never really loved anything she did yeah
I was most impressed by Cobie Smulders
in this movie I thought she had I
publish out of all the actors she tried
the hardest yeah if she gave the most
commitment in the film more than Tom
Cruise yet seen again towards the finale
when they're opening up all these crates
and stuff like that and it's clearly
what she knew is falling apart like I
thought she played that moment really
nicely but with some nuance you know
like there's just some stupid you know
when like everyone's got a stupid
remember in the airplane when they're
flying and then Jack Reacher notices to
people on the plane might be bad guys
I'm like I'm like I've been on a plane
before and you're gonna be up there for
a while oh look ready yeah so then he
just sits they shown in the trailer both
both of the attacks he does they showed
in the trailers he goes what sits down
next to one guy it's your [ __ ]
haircut or some [ __ ] and then he like
does these this move on him run like the
person behind they would have noticed
something at least yeah and I could
forgive that and then then I was like
wait a minute you're in the plane how do
you know this guy's gonna be knocked out
long enough for him to like not wake up
by the time the flight goes and then he
totally like knock someone out into the
bathroom and then he just closes the
door I don't like they're not even
looking at you can't lock it from the
outside did you any jizz yeah this
person's is something and he
not feeling yeah he's not feeling you
like the one you're gonna be in the
flight for hours if you're in there long
enough a flight attendant will come by
and be like excuse me well yeah not to
mention like there are times during
flight where you have to be back at your
seat and they will check okay I feel
like that's the true power of jack
reacher in this movie is he's not super
skilled he just has this thing that he's
a superhero who just has the ability to
make everyone around him dumb for a
while Ike that's how I feel he gets by
in this movie and it's it's a bummer I
didn't especially that scene in the
trailer to run I first thought I was
like what when I saw it in a trailer and
watching the movie i thought it was
justified horribly when he punches
through a window and they justified
because he has a salt shaker in between
his knuckles I'm like there's no way a
salt shaker is gonna be able to possibly
allow him to fully break this glass I
don't know I don't know about that I
don't know what the physics are I mean
like yeah it's a smart idea you grab
something hard what he's supposed to be
human he's supposed to be human jack
reacher kind of gets a little like the
hurt at times yeah yeah no I didn't I
didn't find that completely unbelievable
the way the movie handles it I think
isn't good really because he's clearly
unaffected by that's a bug me I was like
yeah you grab you know salt shakers is
kind of a thick glass a few I just was
kind of surprised it didn't break like
his hands and I've been waiting like the
laws of physics yeah help out any and
all right when he walks away he
immediately throws the gun in a trash
can let's one of the henchmen live he
just has one of the henchmen throw his
gun the path back seat I was like good
the henchman just grab and couldn't
shoot him I wanted that one guy was dead
after that cuz his head's is kind of
like like leaning at the window like I
didn't know that's the thing is you
leave these scenes so many questions of
like is he dead are they just gonna
chill out and not try and bother with
this is some terrible like attempts at
humor in this film died there's one
scene where Tom Cruise is being
interrogated that was kind of funny one
scene where it was kind of funny where
no worries just refusing to answer
understand do not have to yeah but other
than that there was some really bad
attempts
humor in this film see ya for me overall
this film had just no style no real
substance talk is the first time I've
ever felt like Tom Cruise is phoning it
in and i know this is based on a
specific novel so this can't be too big
of a good play but Adam all the no
because I know Jack Reacher is the first
ones based off a novel called one shot I
believe and that's not the first jack
reacher novel and it kind of upsets me
that the next one they went with was a
plot where I've seen Tom Cruise in so
many times where he's a [ __ ] fugitive
that's like four out of the five mission
apostle yeah I don't need to see this
guy on the run again where he's just
trying to clear his name one more time
that was a weird thing that like part of
the crux of his movies like Cobie
Smulders doesn't want Jack Reacher
involved in any of this I could not
figure that out why life me I was like
she's like the number one gun that is
the only dude who might have be able to
help you yeah there's some like force
dialogue that is not bad ass I could
just feel the screenwriters doing it
when because they have that one cool
model that one cool line in the first
jack reacher where he's like do you
think I'm a hero and then he goes into
all this stuff about and that haven't
written to make the bag I drink his own
blood and it's a badass line and then
this one he just suddenly resorts to
like I'm gonna stop I'm gonna talk [ __ ]
to this assassin for a second I'm gonna
break your arms I'm gonna break your
legs under your neck and I was like that
is just not a cool line you can said
something way cooler than that well the
things who I realized is that the first
movie has a villain the asking they hey
they got Verner [ __ ] hertzog to be
like the main villain in that movie and
they also had like one of the Jai
Courtney performances we liked as like
the main henchman and I feel like they
took time to kind of fill the Jai
Courtney roll with that other assassin
guy who's like got the vendetta against
Jack Riegert Reacher this movie doesn't
really have like a villain that's
distinct in any way it's got a couple
high-ranking guys who we see sometimes
and that's about it and then just lots
and lots of henchmen who aren't good at
their jobs so it's like it loses all
these chances to be distinct in any way
and it's just kind
come bummer like and I felt they could
have the main assassin I felt like they
could have had an opportunity to make
him better because he fights Jack
Reacher and Cobie Smulders at once and
then he defeats both of them remembering
when they fight in the kitchen is he
defeats them in a comedic way where Tom
ters gets hit yeah so ue beats him and
it doesn't seem to really affect Tom
Cruise's character when I'm like dude
that could have been a great moment for
you to be like this guy something
serious like yeah it took two of us to
fight him and we lost like he's a real
threat this movie really does seem like
it's picking and choosing at its own
will you know who has power in any
situation and not just letting the
characters be who they are and seeing
how they react to these different crises
it's like it in this scene we're gonna
let this guy have the power but then the
next scene we get AB Jack Reacher yeah
it's like it doesn't seem like it makes
any sense overall in a grand way it's
just like scene by scene it decides who
it wants to win and then we just go with
that like I just think the weirdest part
of this was that on paper they tried
making it seem more personal yet the
first one because of how Jack Reacher is
responding to the situation how it's
escalating Lee affecting him more and
more like when he gives that cool last
each where he's gonna make the guy drink
his own blood from his boot or something
that was effective when you first
watched that movie because it's like
this is really affecting Jack Reacher
more and more he's getting more involved
here they have a girl he's kind of into
and they have a girl who might be his
daughter and yet i'm like this doesn't
feel anywhere near his personal for some
reason well because they're two people
he just met yeah like he just met these
view but he was like but he sounded like
a one past relationship with Cobie
Smulders I get the sense but like in
terms of face time he's just meeting
these people I didn't mind the montage
the beginning was there getting to know
each other but I don't think it's a good
choice because for the personal aspect
of this movie to work we have to see
them build a relationship in more than
just over the phone in the bed of a
truck yeah you know like we need
something to latch on to because
otherwise the movies just telling you
it's personal and it's not letting you
feel that yeah you know it was very void
of an actual mo
yeah it's like I want to see it leaves
you wanting to see the stuff that
happens between all the actions things
that we scare like all those laps is in
time it makes you want to watch the
lapses in time instead I just feel like
this movie doesn't have any redeeming
qualities there are movies that I've
seen this year that I did not like but I
could still walk away from them and go
well here for sure is what was good
about the film here for sure is what
they got right about the film but then
this film I'm like just because there's
a few scenes that kind of work doesn't
make the cool that specific quality of
the film work as all in general though
well yeah when the best scenes are fine
at best ya know like there's not really
much else to go I don't I didn't hate
this movie as much as you did but i also
just wasn't in mist I just hate it
because I'm like dude Tom Cruise I'm
surprised ever since like all that [ __ ]
with the Scientology image and all that
he was really going out of his way to
produce high quality films films where
he was giving it his all even at the
film didn't get like amazing feedback
like night and day for example didn't
get amazing feedback when he still has a
full level of commitment he is awesome
in that movie and it's a distinct movie
from what I'm yeah like it's got a
specific tone thing he was also
releasing mission a possible three rogue
nation goes protocol edge of tomorrow
oblivion that's another one where it's
like that's a specific kind of film and
he gives a great performance and I'm
like this was the first time where I it
seemed like Tom Cruise was just kind of
getting comfortable that he was like
sort of back on top again yeah this is
this is weird Valley didn't need to try
any more like that's what it felt like
and I don't understand why Jack Reacher
seems like it got made because he wanted
it to yeah and I'm surprised that this
movie is the way it is because you know
Tom Cruise has by all accounts a huge
amount of input on the movies he makes
like this should have been great like I
think this is a cool world to see Tom
Cruise in it's a smaller you know a
little more grounded story than like
mission impossible or some of the sci-fi
stuff he does like I like this concept I
like the Tom Cruise version watered a
drifter you
yeah modern day drifter lots of highly
specialized skills but I don't know what
happened with this movie like its name
you completely lose interest in the
whole character yeah and like they have
things that should be almost impossible
to make lackluster like they go to New
Orleans during like a Halloween parade
at some point which should be super cool
it should give it a flare and it just
becomes wallpaper I want to know what
happened to this because I feel like
there's no reason they shouldn't have
had you know something really cool and
distinct on their hands you know like
Jack Reacher the first one surprised
everybody by being more distinct and
cooler than we thought it was gonna be
and more badass than we thought it was
gonna be a better action thriller than
we ever thought it was cooking and this
one is not any of those no no I was
editing the review and I completely
forgot to use my new rating system this
film is horrible what else did you think
I would say all right guys well if you
saw Jack Reacher never go back what did
you think you'll agree with us did you
disagree with us what did you like about
it subscribe to the real rejects sean
has reason to Jerry on Twitter and
Instagram social media manager of the
Facebook sites of bloom house in the
real rejects I thought Danica that the
daughter and Jack Reacher was his like I
was like questioning thinking is this is
real daughter in real life a real life
was I was like a chi Chi looks like
Nicole Kidman I thought she was so bad
that I was like that must be the only
reason she got cast did he have a dollar
nicole kidman yeah I had a few children
Nicole Kidman oh he's got why kids yeah
man that's Wade me this movie paid child
support